don't do that
[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kbhd here and
this is the larger of the two brother
nexuses that came out this year Nexus 6p
it's the successor to the Nexus 6 and
the p apparently stands for premium
which I think is fitting this is one of
the most anticipated smartphones of the
year before it came out and after using
it for nearly a month I can say it has
lived up to a lot of the hype which is
hard to do for a smartphone nowadays and
it's quickly become one of my favorite
smartphones right now for a bunch of
reasons first of all it is a big phone
again it's technically the successor to
the huge Nexus 6 but 6p is a little more
manageable with a slightly smaller 5.7
inch display and a thinner flatter body
and more importantly flat sides that
actually kind of help you with the grip
a lot there's also three colors graphite
aluminum and frost they're all the same
feel on the hand same texture and I like
this stealth graphite look personally a
bit more it sort of hides the visor look
of the glass up top but it is the most
fingerprint magnity of any of them so
you might go with the white if you like
the more traditional Nexus look or you
could Rock us skin which can also look
super dope I'll leave a link to this one
below but yeah Nexus 6p has a super
premium build all metal all the way
around these chamfered edges and a nice
bit of weight to it and it has this
ridged power buttons next to the volume
buttons all of which are relatively
clicky and decently tactile and overall
it's definitely fitting in the premium
package with its industrial design and
the material choices it's Top Notch
which is always awesome to see in a
Nexus the hump on the back of the phone
with the camera and the Flash and the
window for radios to pass through it's
really not all that bad and it actually
spans the whole width of the phone kind
of like the Droid X back in the day so
it still sits flat enough on a table to
type without rocking I personally don't
mind it and it actually kind of helps
tell which side is up when grabbing the
phone without looking the only weird
part of the build for me was the bottom
back panel which felt slightly more
raised on one side than the other like
it kind of didn't quite fit on my review
unit Nexus 6p but my retail units were
just fine one of the coolest New pieces
of Hardware with the new nexuses or is
it nexi I'm I'm gonna go with nexuses
unless someone from Google corrects me
one of the coolest New pieces of Nexus
Hardware is the fingerprint reader on
the back dubbed Nexus imprint it's
really good and knowing how good some of
huawei's other fingerprint readers are
this shouldn't be much of a surprise but
the touch to unlock was really quick
with this one and I really got used to
it being there on the back of the phone
right where my index finger rests to the
point where I'd reach into my pocket and
grab the phone with an unlocking grip
and then it would just be ready to go
before I even got it up to my face so
the unlock is just as fast as using a
power button here but obviously way more
secure the only real downside to it
being on the back is if your phone's
sitting on a table or something you
either have to use that pattern unlock
or I guess pick up the phone to
physically unlock it a little less
convenient but I got used to it alright
so continuing with the theme of Premium
up on the front of this guy you have a
beautiful crispy 5.7 inch Quad HD OLED
display this isn't a huge upgrade on
paper Nexus 6 had a quad HDL display too
but this this one is slightly better
slightly brighter slightly less pink at
low brightness which is a nice
Improvement slightly better view angles
before rainbows out and slightly more
accurate color it still pops like an
ammo LED should but color accuracy is
tight with this one it's a latest
generation Samsung panel so it should be
I'd put this display right up near the
top for any smartphone short of the
Galaxy Note 5 which seemed to get really
bright but overall thumbs up for the
screen on the Nexus 6p oh and the
wallpaper link is right below that like
button you're welcome now you've
probably already noticed that the
display is flanked by a pair of
front-facing stereo speakers they're
outstanding speakers really big loud
crisp full sound easily comparable to
like boom sound from an HTC One M9 or
Moto X pure speakers I've said it before
this makes for an awesome music
listening experience awesome video
watching awesome gaming awesome
conference calls awesome alarm clock
everything sounds great coming from this
phone and that can't be overlooked I
love them now this is still a really
high-end phone in the specs Department
as it should be for the price so inside
you're getting a Snapdragon 810 version
2.1 chip the adreno 430 GPU three
gigabytes of RAM and either 32 64 or if
you're a ball or 128 gigabytes of
storage and these high-end specs paired
with the latest version of Android 6.0
marshmallow translates into a really
smooth experience from top to bottom
front to back inside out using this
phone is awesome it's extremely
responsive and snappy and it handles
pretty much everything I throw at it
like a champ and look I throw a lot at
phones especially when I'm testing them
so I notice when they hang up or when
they stutter or when they start to slow
down or when they can't quite push all
their pixels and a month in this Nexus
very rarely hiccups over much of
anything the one thing it's hiccuped
over the most is probably the camera app
which I'll get to in a second but
everything else multitasking opening and
closing apps web browsing all that fun
stuff buttery gaming 2 has been great I
know there's been you know the concern
over the Snapdragon 810 chip but I have
no problems with them using it here
because this phone only gets a little
little bit warm maybe sometimes now the
heat dispersion is great with the metal
body and performance has been consistent
and clean and smooth I have no
complaints with that so yeah without any
worries about performance you're kind of
just you're free to mess around in the
newest version of Android without
worries of anything hanging up and
marshmallow has been pretty great so far
right out the box there are less
pre-installed apps so you have the
option to install most of Google stuff
from the Play Store and I've always been
a fan of clean stock Android a lot of it
is for aesthetic reasons but it's
getting a lot of functionality
improvements too and this is the stuff
that you see trickle down into other
non-nexis phones later down the road
classic example brand new Android 6.0
feature Google Now on tap so you still
have the Google Now cards but Google Now
on tap is a sort of a next level of
convenience to accessing quick
information basically it reads what's on
your display whatever is text and then
when you press and hold the home button
after that animation and about three or
four seconds of loading it brings up
some cards related to what's on the
screen linking you to more information
about it so for example I'm on someone's
tweet here I hold home to see what's now
on tap give it a few seconds and it
recognizes the person who tweeted and
the stuff that they tweeted about so
then I can go grab a link to go get more
info this can be useful in like a text
conversation maybe someone mentions a
restaurant on now on tap can bring you
more info about it show you a menu give
you a phone number to call and make a
reservation or maybe someone mentions a
movie and you want to see the channel
trailer real quick just neat little
things that can save you a bunch of TAPS
if you know when to use it but the thing
is it's really inconsistent right now
sometimes I hold down and there's
nothing on tap even when I was hoping to
see something specific and other times I
actually try it now on tap twice with
the exact same thing on my screen and
one time it gave me Interstellar and the
Martian and the next time it gave me
Interstellar the Martian and Matt Damon
I'm not really sure why I got that the
second time not the first but yeah now
on top you can definitely tell it's
young it's early it has Room to Grow I
feel like it's in a year or two it'll be
much faster and much more consistent and
useful as it evolves kind of reminds me
of the early days of Google Now when it
didn't have nearly as many cards and yes
you can still access Google Now cards by
holding down the home button and hitting
the Google g at the bottom it's always
there just one extra tap to get into it
I kind of miss just swiping up from the
home button but yeah outside of that
there are plenty of other little new
features here and there in Android 6.0
the new share card with your most
frequent contacts up at the top uh the
new launcher with your most frequent
apps during certain times of the day
also up at the top the new permissions
manager is also much more powerful you
can grant or remove any permissions from
any app at the drop of a hat if you
wanted to which puts all the power in
the user's hands there and of course the
battery optimizations on an app by app
basis as well the battery life on the
Nexus 6p has been pretty damn good we
all know it has a 3450 milliamp hour
battery so even in such a thin form
factor a pretty sizable battery but with
a Quad HD display and all these high-end
internals you don't expect it to get the
longest battery life ever but it does
pretty well I've gotten somewhere
between three and three quarters to four
and a half hours of screen on time which
in my book is like an A A minus
especially for a phone of this size but
it's not the screen on time that's so
impressive about this phone it's the
standby time one of the newest features
in Android 6.0 marshmallow is called dos
which essentially is using the sensors
to recognize when the phone is not being
used sometimes it's face down on a table
or it's in a bag or something for a
while so the phone will refresh things
in the background more slowly less often
to save battery the result is these new
phones barely sip any power in standby
mode which is awesome you can forget to
charge your phone with 50 at night and
wake up the next day with 48 and lighter
days where you don't use the phone a lot
you can end the day with 30 sometimes 40
or more percent battery left because you
can see in the battery charts where it
was dozing and saving a ton of power
which is pretty legit on top of that
this is the phone with USB type c as you
probably saw in the unboxing and
supports fast charging so you can get
something like six or seven hours of use
out of a quick 10 minute charge no no
wireless charging here which is a bit of
a bummer for some people but I always
prefer quick charging if I have the
choice now there's one last big change
with these new nexuses that a lot of
people including me were curious about
and that's the camera Nexus 6p is
rocking a new 12 megapixel Sony sensor
no Optical image stabilization but an F
2.0 aperture laser autofocus and a
really large pixel size apparently this
was a sensor originally designed for
point-and-shoots not smartphone cameras
so that's cool here's what's good with
the camera it's pretty solid definitely
way better than any Nexus camera in the
past although that's not a super high
bar to clear and you can double tap the
power button from anywhere including a
lock screen to launch the new Google
camera app and it's overall quite fast
to snap pictures which gives you a
certain confidence when shooting a photo
that you're going to get it also I
noticed it's a particularly wide angle
lens on the back facing camera and the
photos themselves look quite nice
there's a full-size photo gallery on
mkbhd.com linked below if you want to
check out those full-size images But
Here on YouTube you can see you're
getting pretty sharp photos plenty of
detail in those 12 megapixels not too
saturated but nice color and overall
pretty good looking it does have a
tendency to overexpose though and
dynamic range is probably the biggest
weakness it's not terrible but you
definitely do get blown out highlights
pretty frequently even if you tap to
expose the right place most of my photos
never had any problems on the Shadows
but highlights got blown out all the
time of course a natural way to fix this
is to turn on HDR plus and I did that it
worked and you can see before HDR the
highlights are blown out and after HDR
you get your highlights back so it works
like it should once you get in low light
Nexus 6p photos start to show some grain
as you'd expect but they stay
surprisingly blur free for something
without Optical image stabilization and
basically what it's doing here is
cranking the iso way up and keeping a
relatively fast shutter speed to
compensate for the lack of stabilization
and then relying on really heavy image
processing to get rid of the noise from
such a high ISO you can see in these low
light photos some areas get really soft
because of all the noise removable turns
out again the best trick for all this at
night is to use HDR plus again takes a
little bit slower but the photo once it
processes looks a lot better check it
out regular shot HDR plus regular shot
HDR plus it's definitely it works it's
keeping a more natural and Lively tone
for those low light shots and does
better with noise overall you can tell
the camera and the Nexus 6p is really
not bad I think the area where it hurts
the most from no ois is in the 4K video
where those tiny little shakes from a
handheld shot are normally smoothed out
not so this time around but outside of
that you can really tell Google's put a
lot of work into the stock Google camera
to make image processing better not
overly sharp or overly processed but
pretty natural looking and while there's
no raw or manual modes with the new
camera app you can actually do that
stuff with a third-party app so at the
end of the day Nexus 6p checks a lot of
boxes for me in terms of what I want in
a phone I've talked about how before
there's basically no perfect smartphone
and there's still one or two or three
things that I would have liked to have
seen in this Nexus but as far as Android
phones go this is my new favorite this
is easy a daily driver pick for me and I
really like using it as far as
recommending it goes I think this is one
of the easiest Nexus phones ever for me
to recommend to someone to buy
especially with the much improved camera
the great battery life and just an
overall awesome experience throughout
fast fingerprint reader great display
and awesome performance throughout the
clean bloat free stock Android so if
you're an Android Enthusiast or a
smartphone Enthusiast you're pretty much
good to go this is a smartphone that's
not going to disappoint you at all in
pretty much any way and if you're just
getting into smartphones or just getting
into this budget of a smartphone I still
think it's going to be a great
smartphone to buy especially because
you'll be right up at the front of the
tier for new Android updates and new
features and new things that come along
with what Google tosses in so uh yeah
highly recommended good stuff Google
thanks for watching this review guys if
you enjoyed feel free to hit that thumbs
up button right below and also hit that
subscribe button below if you want to
see more videos like this one again
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace
foreign